we're now joined by dr ashish jaw he's
the dean of brown university school of
public health good to see you dr jah
you know we just heard ben tracy say
that the white house people working at
the white house are waiting to see
who's next it must be very unsettling to
work under those conditions
do you think because there have been so
much so many outbreaks at the white
house that maybe they became
overconfident in their testing or is
there something wrong with the testing
they use that
rapid testing there good morning gail
thank you so much for having me on
the bottom line is that i think they
misunderstood the role of that test the
test is fine there's nothing wrong with
it
but it's not anywhere near perfect and
they decided that somehow that was
enough they didn't need to do masking
they didn't need to do social distancing
that if they tested negative everybody
could go about their business
we knew that wasn't true and we've been
warning that this was likely to happen
and
sorry to see that it has you know the
president has
compared kovid 19 to the flu so
which all the experts say is just
totally incorrect so much so that
facebook
took down a tweet that where he was
saying that when you heard that
what did you think and can you just give
us set the record straight on why there
is such a difference between the two for
people
that may still be confused
yeah so it was it was frustrating
because we've been saying this for and
people have been saying this for so many
months
the bottom line is that covid is about
five to ten times more
deadly than the flu for almost every age
group
and we don't even know the long-term
effects of covid
it may end up being quite substantial so
at this moment
comparing the two i think is
irresponsible and everybody knows that
kobit is much more deadly and
and i was hoping that the president
would have changed his tune after going
through what he's gone through
but that tweet really was upsetting for
a lot of us to see yeah the president's
doctor just released a couple of words
yesterday he said that is he reported no
symptoms that his vital signs remain
stable
yet we're still being told he's not out
of the woods yet what do you need to see
or what do doctors need to see to say
that he is out of the woods what should
we be looking for
well you know what we know about this
disease is that some people will feel
just fine
for a while and then day seven to ten
will all of a sudden take a turn for the
worse so we're still in that time period
for the president obviously we hope that
he's not one of those people we hope he
recovers
easily but we're going to have to watch
through the end of this week and maybe
even into the weekend
before we're going to sire you know a
sense of relief that the president is
through this
five days out dr zhao we still don't
know when he got his last negative test
i think that seems to be very important
for people who might have come in
contact with the president
what do you think would be the reasoning
for not releasing that information
you know gail i am baffled by this i
don't understand why why the white house
is
being evasive on this he's the president
lots of people have been around them
he should and they should just release
the information
it will make it much much easier for
people to know if they were potentially
infected
when he turned positive the fact that
they're being evasive on this really is
baffling to me
all right dr ashish josh thank you so
much for taking time for us this morning
we appreciate it
thank you